each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello hi everyone it's my great pleasure
to introduce David manar who is going to
talk about RFID security and security
testing this is David Wright thank you
very much for trace is my pleasure today
I talk to you about two areas computer
security the example the different range
of approaches we need to make progress
in the area so the first thing I want to
talk to you is about RFID and to do that
of course have to tell you what it is so
RFID is a term that refers to a range of
technologies where a small computer with
an antenna call the tag is attached to a
person a item or a collection of items
and then a different computer called the
reader is able to talk to this little
tag and ask it for the information it
carries and in many cases and the ones
in cases i'll be talking about in this
talk the power comes strictly from the
radio waves the reader there's no
battery to change nothing to wear out
and is what makes it very attractive for
the sort of identification space so the
nintning thing about RFID is the
applications are everywhere this slide
just shows a few of them so you can see
here on the top we have fast track
that's for the California automatic toll
payment system you see credit cards on
the top right where the credit card
sends your credit card number wirelessly
over the air to a reader as it comes in
on the bottom right you have library
books with RFID tags on them which I
will talk about and of course your
driver's licenses here in Washington now
have the option of the so-called
enhanced driver's license which includes
an RFID tag and even United States
passports now include these devices
which I will also talk about but one of
the key problems of these devices is
that what are the security and privacy
implications of using them
the card reader that restricts access to
the state capital says it's this
gentleman I wasn't as Pavley Jonathan
West use is really a security consultant
hired by state senator joe some idiot
italdesign with a homemade antenna and a
laptop west use was able to read radio
waves emitted by pavley's identity card
duplicated and then gain access to a
secured area of the state capitol all
that was done within moments of time
without me aware of it civilians
experiment Illustrated just how easy it
is for a hacker to read those radio
frequency identification cards or RFIDs
from a few feet away if you can read
someone's information and then literally
in a matter of seconds clone their card
you pass yourself off as them imagine
the mischief that people can do so what
this shows is that people use these
devices believing that they have certain
security properties when in fact they
don't and anyone with some basic
electrical engineering knowledge can
come along and build something that
defeats the security of the system one
thing that makes it difficult to design
around these security issues as well as
i said rfid is a range of technologies
on the one hand you have things like the
chips which are used in US passports
they cover a lot of information up to
and including a digital photograph of
you and they can do a lot of computation
up to including RSA signatures on the
other hand you have devices used for
Walmart originally designed for tracking
tubes of toothpaste which are now in
enhanced driver's licenses and the
so-called pass card which are nothing
more than a sort of long-range readable
barcode they can be read it served 5 to
10 meters but don't really have much in
the way of computation so what I did as
part of my work was take a look at some
real deployments to understand what are
the security and privacy issues and how
can we come up with new methods of
addressing these problems so the first
point I want to talk to you about is
library RFID so most San Francisco and
Berkeley public libraries were
considering spending millions of dollars
on rfid tags for every single book in
the library a dollar per book a million
books a million dollars of public funds
the pale
off is that these tags enable easy self
checkout you can walk up to a kiosk wave
the book over them over the kiosk and
automatically figures out who you are
what the book is and checks you out or
as you can see in the picture when you
walk out the library door you walk
through these gates the gates read all
the books in your backpack and if you
haven't checked one of them out it
reminds you that perhaps you need to do
that so there were actually huge public
concerns people coming up to open
meetings people coming to library
trustee meetings about well what is on
these tags who can read them and from
how far so I was able to serve as a pro
bono consultant for this Berkeley Public
Library survived ahlan tiered my
expertise as computer scientists to help
them understand these issues and return
they actually let me ask vendors so what
do you really do tell me and they had to
answer it was great so one of the things
I discovered was that some vendors
actually advocated putting the title and
author of the book on the tag and what's
more these tags could be read by anyone
of a compatible reader so that leads to
an immediate privacy concern of someone
be able to scan you as you walk through
these gates or anywhere like that and
learn exactly what you're reading and it
turns out there's a long history of
people being very concerned about what
you read and other people wanting to not
reveal that information to just anyone
who might be passing by but then we
looked a little bit deeper and said okay
what if you get rid of this title and
author well a lot of different places
also suggested putting the barcode the
library barcode on the RFID tag and this
is sort of a static unique identifier
and it never changes and one of the
things we discovered was this attack we
call hot listing suppose you're
interested in a specific book in the
library for example the FBI circulate a
memo to its agents in late two thousand
three saying be on the lookout for
people with almanacs because we believe
they are using almanacs to plan an
attack on the United States
you can't make this up I can go to a
library that's uses RFID like the Cesar
Chavez public library branch in Oakland
and look at the tags discover the bar
code for the almanacs and now because
it's a static unique identifier that
never changes every time I see that
particular bar code in the future I know
it's from Oakland and I know it's the
Quran or an almanac or what have you so
one of the things we did then and say
okay let's work to figure out there's
some new cryptography we could use or
some new different methods we could use
a change these IDs every time and then
we ran to the sort of systems problem of
the actual collision avoidance protocols
used by the ISO 1569 three tags baked in
unique tag identifiers to the collision
avoidance behavior of the radio protocol
and by looking at the collision
avoidance behavior you could just find
out what tag it was even if at the data
level you were rewriting it every time
so our contribution there was a sort of
realized the full serv vertically
integrated systems problem I then moved
on to electronic passports so the
proposed es I'll talk about some
cryptography we came up as a partial
solution for that and there and since
then there have been new air interface
protocols which don't have the same
problems that we talked about does that
answer your question so the next
deployment want to talk to you about is
passport so here remember I said that
passports are answered on the other end
of the spectrum of computation digital
passport includes your name your
passport number a photograph of you and
your nationality so if you take a look
at your passport you have all this
information here on the front cover like
your picture name passport number so on
so forth all of that is on the chip
inside the passport for instance my
passport I can tell by looking at the
small symbol actually has the chip
inside of it the original deployment
choice of the United States included no
encryption or authentication of the chip
so anyone the compatible reader could go
up to your passport and say excuse me
I'd like to know who you are
and the password would send all of us
over to the reader yes so alleged it is
a found a cage in the cover does it or
does it not because if they're close
password is a fairly good part of the
age if it's made of metal so the
question is is there a Faraday occasion
to cover and the answer is there is now
there was not in the original deployment
choices so I'm talking about back in
2005 when we start looking at this the
United States State Department published
or what they call concept of operations
where he said this is what we're going
to do and the Faraday cage was not part
of that concept does answer your
question so the key problems with this
original deployment choices are the full
first of all the privacy issue someone
comes up and read your passport they
know who you are even if you didn't want
to tell them but there's actually a more
serious issue the more serious issue is
that because it didn't check whether or
not the information was coming from a
real passport or from a small homemade
device like the one you saw Jonathan
West use made what this means is that if
I scan your passport I can pretend that
I'm using your passport and anything
that uses automatics sort of use of the
passport for example Australia trialed
gates which would swipe your passport a
new face recognition to figure out if
you're allowed in the country or not so
I notice here you have these nice gates
of the introduction to entry the
microsoft research yeah so imagine
coming back to your home country swiping
your passport and then having a picture
a camera look at your face look at your
passports picture that's presented and
say oh is this the right person or not
because the original choices didn't
actually check whether the information
was coming from a real passport or not I
could try to use your passport and the
reason this is important is because it
lets me try to imitate your face at home
instead of at the border so I can go
scan someone who looks somewhat like me
and then figure out what the correct
Polaroid to hold up to the camera is at
home or facial prosthetics or what have
you but the point is that because the
biometrics are coming from the passport
and it didn't authenticate the chip yes
so you're saying there was some kind of
graphic signature
that paired the identifying information
with the face so you could just replace
the picture and then show up and it
looks like you yeah so the question is
there is there was a was there a
cryptographic signature that made sure
thats I couldn't just replace the
identifying information directly any
answer is yes there's something they
called passive authentication where the
issuing nation signs the information
we've recently learned that no one
checks those signatures but that was not
part of my work and then the final thing
of course is this this was a you know
reveals nationality and so it's a US
citizen detector which might be bad so
what we did is we wrote this down we
submitted a formal comment to a State
Department with Electronic Frontier
Foundation 2400 other people sent in
negative comments about these choices
and there was public outcry
demonstrations what have you so a State
Department end up adding encryption to e
passports now whenever we have
encryption of course a key question is
where do you get the key used for the
encryption and the answer is the key is
actually derived from information that's
right here on the front cover of the
passport when you go to the airport as I
did in San Francisco International
before coming here you either swipe your
passport or have it scanned and then the
Machine gets this key authenticates the
passport and obtains the information
this works for the passport workflow
where you're already giving your
passport to somebody but it doesn't work
for other rfid applications for the
whole point of radio frequency and
remote reads is to not touch things yes
but now that you have to expose them or
over the pocket what does it are many
tools again who do you bark or do not do
it when you just read information so the
question is what does the RFID do the 2d
barcode does not do and the answer is in
the particular choices they ended up
with there's no difference but there is
an optional feature not yet implemented
where the chip would do a challenge
response protocol to prove it was an
actual chip made in an actual passport
facility this is called active
authentication it is an optional feature
it has not been implementing the current
US passports to my knowledge does answer
your question does answer your question
yes
doesn't answer my question what does
that do to the digital signature doesn't
well the active authentication would
actually authenticate the specific chip
not just the actual digital's not just
the information on it part of the
signature include the trip I do well how
would you authenticate particular chip
has that specific ID does answer your
question okay yeah it's a cloning issue
so so the question was what does
stitches why would challenge response do
something different from just signing
the information on the passport and the
quite answer I gave is that it's a
question about trying to prevent cloning
of the actual chip involved but the
point I'm trying to make here is that
they we found a solution here for this
problem that integrates with the
workflow of actual passports but what
are we going to do for other RFID
deployments and you think about it
there's an underlying theoretical
problem here and it's a problem I like
the call scalable private authentication
so here you see Alice talking one of two
different RFID devices and you see an
adversary listening in on them and I'm
going to show you a protocol which
solves the problem of private
authentication that is Alice should be
able to authenticate to the chip and
vice versa without the adversary knowing
which tag is being read by Alice I want
to talk about solutions for a subclass
of all the tags we have where we can do
some cryptography so the solutions i'll
talk about will cover some of the rfid
devices in existence but not all and
i'll argue there's still some
interesting problems to solve even in
this class of devices where we allowed
to share keys between Alice and the tags
and where we allowed to do a little bit
of cryptography so the first protocol I
want to show you is a protocol where
Allison the tag share it a secret key
Alice begins by creating a random nonce
a 32-bit value that never repeats sends
it to the tag the tag crazed its own
knots and it evaluates pseudo-random
function on the shared key in the two
nonsense and just to briefly argue why
does give us some nice properties an
adversary who doesn't know this
ki won't be able to predict what the
proper value is to respond as the tag
and so won't be able to impersonate a
particular tag by the same token because
this is a pseudo-random function without
knowing the secret keys of different
tags the adversary won't be able to
figure out whether a particular response
came from tagged a or tag be and the
only problem here is now scaling so in
this picture Alice and the tag share a
key and they both know they share a key
what happens when a new tag shows of
analysis field of vision that she's
never seen before well naive thing to do
is Allison needs to try a different key
for each tag could possibly be until she
succeeds so that scales linearly as a
number of tags scales and the question
is can we do better so let me show you
something an attempt to do better that
doesn't actually work so the attempt is
this let's give every key a unique
identifier have the tag simply say I'm
using key number five and then Alice has
no problem with scaling she just looks
up key number five and some hash table
and said okay this is the key I want to
use great and we run the protocol or any
other authenticated key exchange or any
other you know protocol that you happen
to like but the problem with this is
that it breaks our privacy guarantees
weekend with a unique static identifier
for every tag and the question now is
what can we do if the tags ends anything
that's correlated with its identity it
seems like the average they will get an
idea of which tag it is which breaks our
privacy guarantee but if we don't that
Alice doesn't know which key to use
which breaks are scaling problem so my
solution to this is to use a so-called
Tree of Secrets Alice knows every single
secret key in this tree each tag is
associative a leaf in this tree and
knows the secrets on the path from the
root to the leaf so this particular
picture you have a tag on a library book
and it knows the right secret than the
left secret and the left secret and what
we do in order to i authenticate and
identify a particular tag is the
following we start out
using the probe I showed you and say
okay I'm on the left subtree or the
right subtree which of these two keys do
I share so we can use the protocol I
showed you which scales linearly in a
number of possible keys but there's only
two keys here just a left key and the
right key and the Alice and a tag can
figure out which one they share and then
walk down to the right subtree while an
adversary who's listening in has no idea
where they are similarly they can do the
same thing left subtree you're right
subtree and go on and so on and so forth
until they reach a leaf and they
discover yes so the question is what the
average saves a neighbor the bomb the
tree and that's a question about sort of
key tags sharing keys for right now I'm
talking about adversary had sort of a
radio only adversary and in order to
mitigate and I'll get to this question
just a second so for radio only
adversary the adversary can't tell
anything about which which tag it is and
we get scaling its logarithmic in the
number of tags now Stewart's question is
what if the adversary happens to be one
of the neighboring tax like suppose
you've broken into one of these tags and
extractive secret keys in that case it's
an interesting question about trading
off privacy for you know efficiency that
other people have actually followed up
on my original work and looked at when
particular you don't need a fully
branching binary tree you can actually
have a multiple larger branching factor
even different branching factors at
different parts of the tree so the very
nice paper at pat's 2006 which talks
about how to make the trade-offs based
on how many tags you think will be
broken into and different efficiency
metrics you might have such as the
amount of communication or amount of
computation for the reader does answer
your question Stewart other questions so
far so what I want to show you on this
slide is a comparison just a simple
comparison between the asymptotics and
then the actual concrete numbers for
implementation for a
back-of-the-envelope implementation of
the scheme for to the 20 or 1 million
tech
so you can see here that it scales
better than the sort of naive scheme of
trying everything every tag in turn but
also scales better than a scheme where
you try to do some pre-computation ahead
of time and treat it as sort of a key
cracking problem and do like a trade-off
time-space trade-off but here at the
bottom we have like again concrete
numbers for the reader time reader space
space and communication for the tag and
for the reader just to give you some
idea of like how we could actually make
this work in an actual implementation so
the way the sort of thing I want to
leave you with from this part of the
talk in this particular project is this
is a story where we start off by looking
at practice real deployments of RFID we
discovered there was a fundamental
problem private authentication and
scaling private authentication and then
we need to come up a new algorithm to
solve this problem which I've just
showed you I want to change directions
now to talk about some of the work I did
while I was an intern here at Microsoft
and that's in software security looking
for serious bugs now as i'm sure people
here all familiar with these bugs are
quite common and in fact if you take a
look at this URL you can go to the
computer emergency response team
statistics and look at you know how many
bugs were in 2007 or how many bugs were
in april of your favorite year well in
2007 or 6515 such bugs reported all
major vendors Apple Adobe Microsoft many
others and as you probably know for each
bug writing a patch queuing a patch
releasing is very costly so we'd like to
figure out a way to have fewer of these
bugs and mitigate these bugs as early as
possible the way I like to think about
sort of work in this general area is
there's a sort of a bug cycle we start
off where we write a bug we don't really
mean to write a bug what we do and then
we find a bug we're more likely someone
else finds a bug we have the bug
reported to us we try to fix the bug and
then we write another bug so there's a
lot of work on how not to write bugs in
the first place
you it's wonderful yeah so so
there's a lot of work on how not to
write bugs in the first place and if you
can do that you should obviously but but
sometimes we don't have that luxury and
sometimes you know we have legacy code
or we have other things that prevent us
from using techniques there's not right
bugs in the first place so my work and
I'm going to talk to you about is been
focused here on the sort of finding bugs
and reporting them part of the cycle and
that's work i did here Patrice and
Michael 11 when I was an intern here at
microsoft research I've continued to do
back at university California Berkeley
so the jumping-off point for this work
is a classical technique called fuzz
testing whose story actually does begin
on a dark and stormy night in the in the
middle of Madison Wisconsin professor
bart miller university of
wisconsin-madison is dialing into the
modem pool and he notices that the line
noise from these storm is causing his
utilities the crash so he realizes that
what nature can do by chance man can do
by design and he gets two of his
graduate students to write a line noise
generator for his favorite unix
utilities and it finds lots of bugs so
today one implementation of this basic
idea is the following you pick a seed
file where you get the seed file from is
up to you you can get it from Bartlett's
familiar quotations you can generally
purely at random or you could have some
other heuristics to generate it then you
take random bytes here highlighted in
red change them some other random bytes
feed it to your program and co does it
crash or does it not crash so there's a
very simple very you know so
straightforward way of testing your
program miller himself refers to fuzz
testing and sticks and stones kind of
testing but it's remarkably effective so
from the original paper they found
between a quarter to a third of all the
unix utilities and binutils crash
depending on the particular version of
unix they looked at and of course the
microsoft security event one life cycle
now requires a hundred thousand fuzzed
files before releasing any software to
the wild and i can give you many many
more anecdotal report
so fuzz testings remarkable
effectiveness finding high-value
security bugs but the problem of this
particular approach is it doesn't handle
unlikely paths here's a small piece of
code which I hope none of us will ever
write for real it simply compares the
very first character of the input to be
and crashes if it's equal and as you can
see if you're just randomly testing you
have a very low chance of hitting this
particular bug so the fix is something
called white box fuzz testing that I
worked on here which combines his idea
of fuzz testing with this idea of
dynamic test generation so let me now
tell you what is dynamic test generation
so dynamic test generation we trace the
dynamic execution of your favorite
program we capture a symbolic path
condition predicates about the input
that have to be true to go down this
path we didn't pick a new path we want
to explore and come up with a new
symbolic formula for that path we have a
constraint solver which tries to solve
this new path condition if it can solve
the new path condition we extract a new
input from the result from the result
and run the program thereby expanding
the coverage of the program that we've
tested so this was originally developed
by a sort of pair of seminal papers won
by good for Ireland and sin other by
cation engler and the idea of using sort
of symbolic execution goes back to sort
of static test generation ideas as far
back as king in 1976 so let me now show
you this idea in practice on this
particular small program so this is a
program we had before it simply compares
the first input to be and crashes of its
equal let's run it on the input good see
what happens well if we run on this
particular input we come up with path
constraint that says okay the first
letter of the input is not equal to B
that's the one predicate we tested on
the input to go down this particular
path we want to come of a new path
through the program there's really only
one logical choice it's take the other
direction of the if statement so we need
eight this path condition and then we
feed this to our tame constraint solver
in the corner we ask the constraint
solver to find a new input
satisfies this constraint the constraint
solver says okay I have one for you
boo'd we run the program and then it
crashes so we've now overcome the
unlikely paths problem yes the
constraints on visibility to find ways
to get to all pass this
ultimately all right so the question is
isn't this the halting problem and the
answer is yes finding all paths is
difficult which is why we end up this
regime where it turns out empirically
constraints over does very well on many
of the paths we want to solve for y it
does very well as an interesting
research question and that's something
that I actually have an undergraduate
working on at the moment who's trying to
characterize some of the reasons why
that might be true for example in the
tool I built at Berkeley which uses the
constraint solver stp seventy percent of
the time we call constraints of it
returns in under a second with an answer
and we're trying to figure out what is
it about program real programs that lead
to that leads to that so this also
touches another so Josh's question also
touches on this other issue of scale
right so the first generation tools are
extremely exciting but you know they
look at serve smaller programs and the
question now is how can we scale them up
the larger programs maybe the constraint
solver will fall over maybe we don't
know how to instrument large programs I
think there's some other questions that
come up but I want to focus on the
search strategy question and I'm going
to argue that the depth-first search
approach which the early tools used
doesn't let them scale as much as we
would like so here's a slightly more
complicated program and you can see here
we've run the input good again we've
come up nice for predicates that it
generates forces the path condition and
now the question is ok we have a much
larger program search space than even
the small program I just showed you what
do we do the search well the initial
choices a very natural initial choices
just use depth-first search will take
the last condition will negate it go
down this path and then symbolically
re-execute the entire program with the
new input and continue doing this over
and over and over again so we keep
symbolically re executing and then doing
a depth-first search now the reason this
is particularly unfortunate in large
programs is just the way the economics
work out is this for a typical program
that's very large you might have the
time to create a symbolic trace be 25
minutes there might be thousands of path
conditions or thousands of
it gets in that pan condition each one
correspond to a different if statement
or a different branch you could try to
go down and the time for each branch to
solve generating new test case and check
that taste case for crash is about a
second so what we want to do is amortize
the expensive work of generating these
paths conditions over many new test
cases and the reason for that is each
test case is a bite at the Apple each
test case is an opportunity to find a
new bug that will justify all the hard
work we've done so far and so we had to
come up with new search strategy that
lets us do this the answer is something
called a generational search so a
generational search you see the initial
path taken good and what happens is we
generate each of the test cases we can
get to by flipping one of the predicates
in the path condition and so we get sort
of four test cases in this example
instead of just one and you see the sort
of set of test cases we generate here at
the bottom we call these generation one
test cases the seed files generation 0
we generate generation 1 test cases and
then the force we can re-execute on any
of those to get generation two test
cases generation 3 and so on and so
forth the overall search space for the
program now looks like this so let me
tell you what you're looking at here on
the bottom you see the actual test case
is Jerry by this technique above them
you see a number which represents the
generation of that test case and then
the bomb represents test cases that
actually crash so after only three
generations three symbolic executions
you end up hitting different test cases
that crash instead of with the
depth-first search having to walk all
the way from left to right through the
search space yes
that's a big part so the question is
we're very trades dependent and isn't
that a big part of the overhead and the
answer is yes you are tres dependent but
we but we manage get lots of different
test cases from each trace and that's
one of the things that makes the search
strategy better than the previous search
strategies were employed does answer
your question Green is the same thing
proof obvious optimization cover a very
small particles if you don't come close
to kind of you know the bad parts of the
program in cases where you don't even
have a good trace to it right so the
question is you know what happens if
there's a part of the program we don't
have a trace that's nearby it what
happens then and the answer I would say
is that that's where the art and picking
the seed files comes in for example or
trying to figure out if there are parts
of the program you haven't covered yet
but you need to direct the technique
towards does that does answer your
question so one things i work till I was
here is this idea of active property
checking so the basic technique I just
showed you looked at code coverage we
came up with new paths that cover new
parts of the code that haven't been
tested yet but of course there are
security bugs that don't actually show
up in the path condition for example you
might observe that there is a buffer and
the index depends on the input and the
way we can reason about and we would
like to know if that index can ever be
outside the bounds of the buffer or we
might know because perhaps someone has
given us a you know a saddle annotation
that says this particular parameter
should never be known to this particular
function we would like to know if we can
solve for an input that makes a
parameter know or maybe we have a
division and the denominator depends on
the particular input we want to see can
we solve for division by zero so I
worked in ways to sort of check many
properties simultaneously and the way I
like to talk about this now is sort of
dividing the solver queries and it serve
two types one type is coverage seeking
where we're looking for new inputs
increase our coverage of the state space
and coverage of the program but the
others are served bug seeking where we
say ok I'm going to solve for a bug and
see what happens I want to talk to you
about one particular type of bug that I
think is a really great fit for this
technique and where I've had to develop
some new methods to look for this kind
of bug and that bug is integer overflow
integer underflow and other
integer bugs these are bugs that come
out because programmers believe machine
arithmetic is unbounded and works just
like your attic we all learned in school
it doesn't and what happens is that it
leaves these subtle bugs that can really
confound our traditional approaches to
find security flaws so for example the
one of the traditional things that we do
is use stack analysis but reasoning
precisely about the values of integer
value variables is hard which leads in
many false positives and leads to
programmers turning off the tool there's
a humorous quote from Lina's Torvalds
about GCC's attempt at finding such bugs
in 2001 where he refers is so broken
it's not even funny now we've made a lot
of progress since then but it's still a
fundamental issue another approach that
we often use in security is to have a
runtime monitor that looks for unsafe
behavior and in terminator program it
looks like we're doing something not
safe but the problem here is that there
are been eyeing integer overflows some
code in cryptography for instance might
use your overflows to do a very fast
modular reduction if you terminate the
program when that kind of overflow
happens you'll make a very angry user in
contrast we can use ideas about these
bugs to direct our search and only
report test cases generated there are
real serious bugs so in slogan formstack
analysis wastes of programmers time run
time analysis wasted users time but
using for dynamic test duration white
box fuzzing only wastes the tools time
and at ten cents an hour for the tools
time versus more than ten cents an hour
for my time I know which one I'd rather
use so there's a particular kind of bug
this is a piece of code that you might
write if you're trying to bounce check
this integer X before passing it the
copy bytes unfortunately for me this
particular integer is signed and if it X
is equal to negative 1 then it will pass
the bounds check but this copy bytes has
a prototype which says it's an unsigned
integer so when I pass negative 1 into
this particular function it will be
you promoted to an unsigned integer and
we're going to copy a few more than 800
bytes so the bug pattern here is we're
treating the same value as signed and
then as unsigned or vice versa so what I
like to think about this is by having
sort of four point lattice of types
every value in the program starts as
unknown we don't know if it's signed or
unsigned if we see it as an argument to
assign comparison or unsigned comparison
that we can give it a type and we see as
an argument to both one after the other
then we can move it to this bottom value
which indicates a potential bug the way
that interacts with my the technique I
talk to you about so far is that if you
see a tainted program value a program
value can reason about that has a type
bottom you can solve for an input that
will make that equal negative 1 y
negative 1 because that will exhibit the
difference between sign on some
comparison and so what I developed our
methods to infer these types in a memory
efficient way over very long traces
because it turns out as I'll show you in
a few slides the traces which we dealers
several hundreds of millions of
instructions long so my first attempts
at inferring these types automatically
were not memory efficient in the size of
the trace and so I end up running out of
memory on real programs so I developed a
method which attempts to have a very
small amount of memory in order to keep
track of only the live variables each
point the program that might have
different types so if you put this all
together the architecture looks
something like this you come up with an
initial input you check it for crashes
then you trace the program on that
particular input you gather some
constraints for your constraint solver
you solve the constraints get a whole
bunch of new inputs and you move on and
repeat the cycle so I've been privileged
put to have be involved in sort of two
different systems that do this one is
sage here at Microsoft and the other one
is called smart fuzz it's what I wrote
at University of California Berkeley and
I want to serve share with you some of
the initial experiment experiences that
you know we've had so sage was
originally redoute released internally
microsoft april two thousand seven and
since then found dozens of new security
bugs which had been missed by black box
fuzzing stack analysis and human code
review
it's bugs that if they had been found
externally the Microsoft would have
resulted in security fix and you can see
here that there's been a number of
people have worked on stage showing the
amount of investments that Microsoft has
put into it I want to show you an
example of such a bug so this is a bug
and animated icon parsing some of you
may be familiar with this bug already on
the left is the initial seed file for
sage that we fed to it on the right is
an example input generated by sage after
seven hours and 36 minutes which shows
the bug in action like you run the code
on this particular input it will crash
and the crash is the place that has the
bug there's particular bug only exhibits
if there's two so-called a nih records
so on the left-hand side the you can see
we've highlighted the little list record
type and on the right hand side it's
been changed to an a nih and you can see
there's another one up at the top so
sage was able to figure out that oh
goodness there's a set this the code is
looking for a nih record synthesize a
new test case it has to a nih records
and that was what was required to show
the bug and you can see that just
randomly testing you'd have a 1 into a
32 chance of coming up with such a bug
but i want to show you something that i
think is even more interesting and
that's what happens with the running
sage on a particular media file format
starting with a 100 0 bytes so this is
our initial input 100 0 bytes we didn't
generated a lot of different test cases
but one of them one of those different
test cases had this our AFF at the top
so sage was able to figure out that the
program was comparing the first four
bytes to our FF and generate a new test
case that makes that particular
condition true and then that generate
several more test cases one of which had
the particular file type and so on and
so forth to the different generation
sage discovers more about the different
parts of the program they're looking for
different parts of the input file and
here after ten generations sage
generates a new test case that actually
crashes the program now what's
interesting after only three generations
for well-formed seed file is an actual
playing media file you in
was the same sort of crash which shows
that even though sage was able to come
up with the structure of the input still
again the choice the seed file makes a
big difference so for the rest of talk
to I'm going to talk a little bit more
about smartphones which is the
implementation of these ideas I've
worked on that Berkeley this uses the
valgrind framework for binary
instrumentation which runs on linux
programs i use the stp solver from
Stanford although we've now actually
generalize that use III and a couple
other solvers and it's available on
sourceforge you can download a virtual
machine but pre-installed if you want to
run it and it's on sourceforge net but
the first thing I talk about is like
both of these tools now scale to real
programs with millions of instructions
per trays so these are two tables that
show you the source lines of code where
applicable and the number of x86
instructions are typical trace so you
can see here above smartphones and sage
now handle code with hundreds of
millions of x86 instructions per traits
and perform this kind of looking for
constraints jarang path conditions and
in solving the path conditions I'm going
to talk to you about some experiments
idea with smart fuzz where I took six
Linux programs I took three seed files
each and for each program each seed file
ran 24 hours with this tool and 24 hours
moves up which is a black box testing
tool that's roughly comparable to the
file fuzzer used here in microsoft and I
use the Amazon Elastic Compute cloud to
run these machines over about 50
different you know instances over a
weekend so Amazon is great because you
can check out a machine with two gigs of
RAM for ten cents an hour or seven gigs
of RAM for forty cents an hour so you
can really just sort of summon lots of
machines that do your bidding and then
get take them and put them back when
you're done so you don't need a cluster
anymore to do this kind of work and the
interesting thing about this of course
is that both of these techniques both of
white box fuzzing black box buzzing give
you millions and millions of test cases
so you have to figure out how do we sort
of pan through all different test cases
for the few ones the fuse flecks of gold
which exhibit bugs we didn't know about
before which are high value and which
are worth fixing in other words how we
find the right
tests so for linux my answer is to use
Val goons min check this is a tool that
checks the execution of your program for
memory memory safety violations things
like memory leaks writing the memory you
shouldn't be writing to reading memory
should be writing reading from uses of
uninitialized values a whole passel of
other properties you probably don't want
violated in your particular program but
you can of course use your favorite bug
Oracle so if you like at verifier you
can use that or if you have any other
things you like using you can use that
yes precision or metrically is one level
of precision really and so it does have
a slow down so the question is what
level pursues do I recommend using them
check with any answers there's really
only one by default and that's the 1
i've been using it's about 225 x does
answer your question so the question is
what does that verifier do and the
answer is that verifier it's a plug-in
architecture you pick what to do so in
the experiments I did when I was here we
looked at the electric fence sort of
mode of that verifier where puts a guard
page either before or after a particular
memory object that was the main thing
that I used that verifier with when I
was here
so the question is so questions valgrind
have more precision in its in its checks
and what I had Microsoft so the answer
is that way is roughly comparable to
true scan in what it's looking for and
the precision it's looking for apt
verifier is less precise and looks for
less but on the other hand a verifier is
a much less of a slow down for the
checking so I have fair fires have
almost unnoticeable whereas this is a
225 x slow down doesn't answer your
question yep 25 explode out so the
traces you generate especially if
there's non-determinism in the program
are you really kind of shaking pats that
occur in practice or you checking thing
you know pastor Jupiter I mean it's
still valuable to find bugs right you
know you're finding the boats that are
likely to occur in the wire so the
question is that my find bugs are likely
to occur in the wild and the answer is
for the kick for the security testing
regime I don't care because of adversary
if he finds any of these bugs is
interested in them but for a sort of
more reliability perspective I don't
think these are going to be good
exemplars of bugs that you'd find in the
wild by random people using them does
answer a question so the nice the other
nice thing about valgrind em check is
people understand in the open source
world about valgrind they've seen it
before it's been around about five years
so when you report valgrind test cases
to people they actually fix them which
is really nice so I was lucky enough to
have nine undergraduates for eight weeks
as part of a team of mentors and we got
them do a project comparing both white
box and black box fuzzing you can see
them here and you can't really read it
but their t-shirt says we found 1
million 12 24 thousand four and fifty
two test cases was at least one valgrind
error and all we got was this lousy
t-shirt ah does that really mean we
found a million bugs well no okay so
there's this problem of bug bucketing
which it turned out to be a rather
serious problem during this summer work
the issue is there's a mini of many
relations between test cases and bugs
one particular test case especially
something as precise as true scan or
valgrind mem check can actually exhibit
multiple bugs because the first bug you
see may not crash the execution of your
program
at the same time it could be the case
that you know you have one sort of
semantic bug which is example by
multiple test cases and in our
experience the developers be very angry
with you if you report duplicate bug and
we were principally reporting to the
mplayer of software project which is an
open source media player that ships with
major linux distributions and the thing
is we're just posting them on your
posting bugs under bugzilla and saying
hi you don't know us but you have an
invalid right bug you might want to look
at and the thing is it was just
interesting sort of interaction where
they would fix these bugs but they still
had no idea who we are or why we were
doing this until much later after
conclusion the project so I want to talk
about how do you actually bucket these
bugs so this is the first thing I tried
it's called stack hash this is the
actual gdb back-trace mareel us test
case that we synthesized sent to the
mplayer developers in bold you see the
actual instruction pointers in the stack
trace and the first thing to try as well
you know I have a hash function floating
around let me just you know put these in
order feed into hash function this is a
bug bucket ID in essence I'm saying up
to the collision resistance of the hash
function two bugs are the same if and
only if they have the same stack trace
this has this turns that has a lot of
problems actually but the main one is
that doesn't work and i know that
because we use it as our main approach
for bug bucketing during the summer work
i mentioned and we actually had about
nine to ten percent duplicate rate as in
the developers look there are bugs that
we reported and said oh look that's a
duplicate right there what was
interesting here is we actually had the
students or concurrently reporting
things too so they really did rely on
the stack cash as their bucket as their
duplicate detection method so I do now
and I don't say this is the end on beale
but I'll talk yes juice
oh the students were choosing which bugs
to root so the question is did the hash
reduce the bug camp from a million to a
hundred the answer is no the students
picked which bugs to report we had nine
students we told each of them to report
at least ten bugs by the end of the
summer so we end up 110 total some
students were more industrious and
others does answer your question so the
question is how do you reduce from
million different bugs to attend use the
undergraduate side report well first of
all we actually use the stack hash in
order to say okay here a distinct
buckets so the million is before any
bucketing whatsoever right so the
undergraduates got to see here the
different buckets which is much less
than a million like several orders of
magnitude I don't have the numbers in
front of me but it did significantly
reduce the number and then the next
question is okay then we give them
criteria well we told them to look for
read a read and write invalid read
invalid right and prefer to report those
because those bugs are more serious but
beyond that we didn't give them any
particular criteria for reporting does
that answer your question okay so what I
use now is this what I call a fuzzy
stack hash and this is motivated by the
fact and the kinds of programs i'm
testing i actually had access to the
source code i can compile with debug
symbols so one problem i noticed when we
were doing this work is that the code
changed quite often so in player
particular at one point was updating
about four times a day while we were
doing this work developers of the
mplayer product really really wants you
to report against the most recent
version of the code or they reject your
bug report out of hand so we have to
recompile in player all the time it is a
small tiny change to the source code
that actually leads a very possibly very
big change in the instruction pointer
and so what would happen is that we'd
have different looking stack traces
because the instruction points would be
different and then report the duplicate
bugs so the approach to get around that
is by using the line of code and the
file the function is in instead of the
instruction pointer and then to be
robust against small
all changes look at all but the last
digit of course it was only a single
digit you take just a single digit
another issue that I observed was you
have a buggy function it's called in
multiple contexts each context is a new
call site is a new stack trace but
they're really semantically the same bug
underneath so in order to address that
the fuzzy stack cash i use now looks
just the top three frames of the stack
trace not the full stack trace yes lemon
we're still looking at what the line
actually has the contents so the
question is why did I take a sort of
fuzzy approach to the line number
instead look at what the line actually
has because the answer is I wanted to be
at the top first of all I didn't think
about what you just said looking at the
line actually has and second of all just
coming up an idea on the fly for why one
might prefer one over the other this
would also let you handle things that
are slightly different about the line
like if there's was hmm okay thank you
thanks for saving me time appreciate it
so yes why didn't you use the relative
right so the question is why not use the
relative offset the beginning the method
and again I didn't think about doing
that that would be right and in
particular the relative officer from
beginning the method wouldn't require
the same level debug information as i
have here right so as i said i don't
believe is the end-all and Beall it's a
service starting point for future work
and what's nice is I actually of a data
set now if anyone wants it about you
know which bugs were marked as
duplicates which worked so you can
imagine going back and redoing this with
a different approach for bucketing so
when I'm going to toe and then what we
did in addition is built a sort of a
front-end for collecting all of these
different bugs called metaphase com this
is a live website you can go there right
now if you want to and it shows you the
stack hash the bucket ID the particular
program that was tested and a link to
download the test case so students use
this to sort of browse through different
bugs that they might want to report to
developers and developers use this to
serve download we were able to provide
links to specific test cases that they
could then use download and try out the
particular bug on their own code to see
if it could reproduce and we've been
adding features for reproducing the most
recent version of software and so on and
so forth so what we found those
experiments remember i talked about
experiments six programs three test
files per program sup random testing
smartphones white box testing we found
that they find different bugs there's
night so overall we found 19 bugs that
they both found and the reason I talked
about a fuzzy stack hash is those when I
say bug here I mean bucket under the
fuzzy stack hash ok so that's why I went
through that to talk to you about what
that is so we've ate bugs at smartphones
found that weren't found by the other
technique 31 the random technique found
that smart fuzz didn't find a 19 in the
intersection so if you break it down
this table shows that we found bugs in
five out of six test programs the
numbers on the left or smartphones
numbers on the right arse off and on two
out of these six we ended up finding
more bugs than the random technique
using smartphones and the bottom you
have the cost per bug
billing at the Amazon ec2 rates as of
februari 2009 so what this says the me
is of course you want to try using both
techniques but you don't know ahead of
time what your program we want where
smartphones would be better or zuf would
be better in particular the gzip which
is a decompression of algorithm that's
used pretty widely smartphones found two
bugs which ends up down nothing so I'm
still trying to figure out exactly why
those bugs are the way they are it's a
very optimized code based it's very fun
to read but this tells us about how the
advantage of effective these two
different types of bugs the other thing
do you want to point out is remember i
talked about bug seeking queries where
we solve for particular kinds of
properties that might correlate with a
bug so this is showing us how many
queries over the older runs we had
particular types how many of them
succeeded so this gets back the question
about solving the query so this tells
you roughly how many was exceeded we
have a timeout of about five seconds for
each query and then of those how many
bug buckets came from each particular
type of query so you can see here we
actually were successful in using them
to find bugs and the signed unsigned
property was the most successful out of
all of our bug seeking queries yes these
three bug categories signed under pro in
sine over cosine inside these are not
destroyed but they're not so what
happened is so Patrice's questions these
are not as sally bugs we have an
overflow and underflow as i argued
earlier what this table is showing you
is we created a new test case from a
property whose name is here we're trying
to force an underflow force an overflow
force assigned unsigned conversion and
then valgrind mem check told us the
resulting test case had an error and
then we applied the fuzzy stash I
discussed earlier it was something else
so it's invalid read and valid write
something like that so again you can see
that these techniques work and that the
sine and sine found the most number of
bug buckets have all the techniques we
tried so the way I see this is this is a
story where we had a beautiful theory
which we showed us the way to an
new method of testing software and the
work that we've been able to do takes
this beautiful theory and puts into
practice with scalable practical tools
that have made a real difference in the
way that people test software so going
forward yes question it was the
methodologies the traces you start with
do you require those to be collected
from the beginning of the program and
you get it given the input or can I in
the middle of a program hook up
something like
so the question is from 10 I start
collecting in the middle of a program
execution and start symbolically
executing the answer is not with my
current infrastructure my infrastructure
uses valgrind valgrind requires loading
the program and the reason for that is
that valgrind actually takes over the
duties of the program loader so valgrind
actually sets up in the same address
space as your guest program room for its
own host code which does the dynamic
binary translation and then does the re
recompilation into x86 and it is not
supported this time to attach to a
running process just finding bugs in the
startup of programs because you know
it takes a while to generate pretty
crazy
so yeah there's well I only find bugs in
the startup of programs the answer is I
don't believe so because what happens we
only look at the constraints from parts
of the program depend on the initial
input and so different inputs at
exercise different parts of the program
will lead to different constraints and
then different bugs especially like
think of a media player program in
player supports like 15 20 different
file formats the bugs we find from the
mp3 playing they're different for what
you find from the wave playing and
different what you find when the avi
playing right that's that's true and so
that's why I've been talking to people
about the checkpointing approaches for
trying to save the state of the initial
part of the program so r enzymes are
speaking gene Cooperman at Northeastern
University he has a checkpointing
approach he thinks could help with this
yes very large number of 16-bit
conversion possibly i'll reserve where
do they come from me if the micro level
said a couple of the 16-bit work but
working units products have 16-bit data
plan so the question is where unix
programs with 16-bit data types i don't
have a great answer for you because i
haven't gone back and traced all those
back to the original source code but my
gut feeling is that mplayer might have
that in the particular file types we're
looking at yes
right so the question is contrasting
with clean so first I was a different
focus clay is bike is focused on very
high code coverage but they're looking
at smaller programs so they do things
like they want to actually keep all the
programs stay in memory and then they
use a fork to try to go down different
code paths whereas i actually do just a
single trace at a time and then I try to
focus on larger traces so I look forward
today where we can take some of those
things they're doing and some things I'm
doing and do really hide code coverage
of really large programs it's just their
main difference their focus on getting
99 percent coverage of grep and my main
focus on finding bugs and in player
beyond that there are lots of other sort
of smaller differences that we could go
into according to my understanding of
clean but or I can tell you more about
the internals of this but I think that
might be best done after the talk like
this answer your question Thanks okay so
going forward we now know how to create
more bugs and anyone will ever be able
to fix unassisted what do we do to fix
these more effectively and stepping back
a bit we now have this amazing ability
to check out hundreds of machines and
use lots and lots of information about
the code base we're working on how can
we use that to help a programmer write
better code more interactively and more
immediately than our current techniques
and that's sort of one of the directions
are really interested in is this part of
the cycle where we report and fix for
example different techniques is
developed here at Microsoft and other
places on for worm defense which try to
synthesize patches immediately given an
example of a worm that exploits a
particular piece of code how does that
change if we go into this regime where
we have a lot of time to create a patch
but the quality has to be higher because
human beings have to maintain and
understand it so that's an example of a
sort of a case of a direction I'm
interested in going in in the future and
with that I thank you for your time and
I welcome your further questions
yes did you catch the bug and
and go tuned to reemphasize that may be
related okay so the question is after I
fix about can I tell the tools we
emphasize a particular piece of code so
my work does not currently work does not
currently allow you to say this
particular function is interesting but
you can rerun the tool with the test
case it generator earlier on and expand
around that particular path and look for
bugs in the patch to the original
problem so yes I can do it but no I
can't do what I would really like to do
would be able see this particular line
of code needs to be exercised quite a
bit does that answer your question
techniques like this one's into like
more interactive programs on networking
protocols by six thank you so so when
you specify test cases this is like the
program taking one input and then
running with it on Tom's document or you
can also do like you know supplying
import program that something turns up
by another input program for something
surprising kind of testing as well right
so the question is what about
interactive programs or protocols right
so my work I show you doesn't work on
that there has been other work it's been
done here at Microsoft it does look at
that and I'm talking to some people the
networking group at Berkeley about how
to look at that particular issue in
principle what you need is a proxy and
let you replay protocol dialogues and
sort of sort of close the entire
environment to let you treat the ginn
taught to let you treat the input to the
whole program as the entire dialogue
between one server one client or what
have you in principle it's possible it's
just it has to be done and there's some
different questions that come up about
how to search the state state space does
answer your question
all right thank you for your time
everyone